thank you for the opportunity and i'm
excited to
talk about my work on pre-training graph
neural networks
okay so um here i'm uh i want to talk
about
applying uh graph neural networks to
application in scientific domains
uh for example uh in chemistry we have
these molecular graphs
where each node is an atom and the each
edge represents the chemical bond
and here we are interested in predicting
the properties of molecules
for example given this kind of molecular
graph we want to predict
whether it's toxic or not in biology
there's also a graph problem for example
we have a protein protein association
graph where each node is a
protein and the edge represents certain
association between
proteins and these associations are very
important to
determine the functionality of the
protein and our
goal is to given this a subgraph
centered around the
protein node we want to predict whether
this center protein
node has certain biological activity or
not
so what i want to say is that about in
many scientific domains this
graph problem appears a lot and we want
to apply
gnn to solve this problem
and uh just to review how gns can be
used for graph classification
so gns obtain an embedding of the entire
graph by following two steps
first um given this molecular graph
let's say graph let's say molecule
we obtain the embedding of node by
iteratively aggregate neighboring
information
once we do that we once we obtain this
node embedding we can pull
this node in very globally to obtain the
embedding
of the entire graph and once we obtain
this embedding of the entire graph we
can use it
but we can apply a linear function on
top of it to predict
whether this entire graph is let's say
toxic or not
and just to say what this means is that
uh
here the node embedding is trying to
capture the local neighborhood structure
uh around each node if we apply k-hop
gnns we will just know the embedding
should capture k-hop
local neighborhood and then the
embedding of the entire graph
can uh is basically aggregating this
local structure
though do not know the embedding that is
capturing the
local neighborhood structure
and uh and this is how gna work and
now i'm going to talk about challenges
of how applying machine learning
to us these scientific domains and there
are basically two fundamental challenges
the first challenge of applying machine
learning to scientific domains
is that the scarcity of labeled data
obtaining labels in the scientific
domains
requires expensive lab experiments for
example to
say whether molecule is toxic or not you
we need to perform wet lab experiments
and these are very expensive as a result
we cannot get
a lot of training data and machine
learning models tend to overfit
to this small training data another
important
issue is that out of distribution
prediction meaning that
test examples we want to make prediction
on tend to be very different
from training examples and this is
really the nature of scientific
discovery
because in scientific discovery we want
to discover some new molecule
that is inherently very different from
from your training molecules
and in these domains machine learning
models are extrapolated poorly
and especially these two challenges are
becoming more challenging
for deep learning the first
the first point of the label scarcity
deep learning models have a lot of
parameters to train
uh typically in the order of millions
and uh and in this regime
the number of training data is much less
than the number of parameters
and deep learning models are extremely
prone to overfitting on small data
small label data another issue is that
deep learning models are
known to extrapolate poorly and it's
reported that
models often make predictions based on
spurious correlation in a data set
without
understanding the true causal mechanism
of how to
make prediction so let's consider this a
toy example
of a mid image classification between
polar bear and brown bear
uh whose image is shown here so
during training let's say our training
data for
in our training data most polar bears
have snow background like this
and most brown bears have a grass
background like this
and as a result the model can learn to
predict
make prediction of whether it's a the
given image is polar bear or
brown bear based on the image background
rather than
animal itself because that's sufficient
to make prediction over the over the
training dataset
but what if at this time if we see polar
bear
on the grass then the model will uh
because the model is not
understanding the the the the
this prediction test the model will
perform fully on
on the on the data on the test data that
is different from
training data and the model is uh just
capturing this kind of spherical
spurious correlation in the training
data set
and our key idea or the goal
uh given these challenges is that we
want to improve models out of
distribution performance even
with limited data and the way we do this
is to inject domain knowledge into a
model before
we apply them on scarcity label tasks
and this work this may work because the
model
already knows the domain knowledge
before the model is training on on our
downstream data so that the model can
generate as well
without many test specific label data
and uh and the model may be able to
extract
essential non-spurious uh pattern in the
data
uh which allows the model to better
extrapolate
uh to the antenna to to the test data
that's
the very different from training data
and the very effective solution to
inject domain knowledge into model
is called pre-training and we train a
model
on relevant tasks that's different from
um a gunship task where data is abundant
and after we portray in the model the
model's parameter or
already contains some domain knowledge
and once this is done we can up transfer
this uh model parameter to the
downstream task
which is what we care about and which
where we have small number of data
and and we can start from the
pre-trained parameter and find
two the the the the planet
on the downstream tasks
um and uh just to mention that
pre-training has been
hugely successful in in the domain of
computer vision and natural language
processing and it's reported that
retraining pulp
improves labor efficiency also
pre-training
improves all distribution
performance and
because of this and
we think retraining can be a very
powerful solution
to the scientific applications and those
two challenges are
scarce labels and auto distribution
prediction
so now we motivated this pre-training
gnns
to solve the important problem in
scientific uh
applications so let's consider you know
actually pretend gnns
and our work is about
designing gnn speed training strategies
and we want to systematically invade
investigate the following two questions
how
effective is preaching gns and what is
the effective
pre-training strategies so
as a running example let's think about
molecular property prediction task
prediction for drug discovery the given
molecule we want to predict
its toxicity or biological activity
and the very naive strategy is
multi-task supervised pre-training
on relevant labels this means that in
the
for example chemical database we have
all the
um experimental measurements of
various toxicity and biological
activities of
a lot of molecules and we can first
pre-train gnns to predict
those very diverse biological activity
or toxicity
and then we expect gns parameter to
capture
some chemistry domain knowledge which
can be trunk
whose and then we can transfer that
parameter to our downstream task
and the setting that we consider is uh
to to study
whether this naive strategy is effective
uh we will
consider this setting we consider this
binary classification of molecules
given molecule we want to judge whether
it's a negative or positive
and and we for the supervised
pre-training part
uh we consid we consider predicting more
than a thousand
diverse binary assays
annotated over 450
000 molecules so there are a lot of data
uh in this
pre-training stage and then we apply
transfer
the parameter to our downstream test uh
which is the eighth
molecular classification data says those
are relatively small
uh about the thousand to hundred
thousand molecules
and and and for the data split uh for
for
on the downstream task we consider the
scaffold split
uh which makes the test molecules out of
distribution
and it turns out that the knife strategy
of this multitask supply speed training
on relevant labels
doesn't work very well it gives a
limited
performance improvement on downstream
tasks and even
uh leads to negative transfer
which means that the pre-chain model
performs worse than randomly
initialized model so here's the uh table
uh here is a figure
so we have a eight uh downstream
of data sets and and the y-axis
is the raw auc improvement over no
pre-training baseline so this purple
is a non-pre-trained baseline and we see
that naive strategy
sometimes work well uh but for
this two data sets it's actually
performing worse
than non-pre-trained randomly
initialized baseline
so this is uh kind of not desirable
we want pretend model to perform better
um so how what is the
then we moved on to our next question
what is the effective
training strategy and our key idea
is to portray both node and graph
embeddings
so that gnns can capture domain specific
knowledge
about the graph at the both local and
global level so
so in the ninth strategy we pretend
genens
only at the level of graph use this
graph embedding to
make a various prediction but we think
uh
it's important to also pre-training this
node embedding
because these node embeddings are
aggregated to generate the embedding of
the entire graph
so we we need to have a high quality
node in bedding
that capture the local neighborhood
structure well
so and the the intuition behind this is
that
so here's the figure the the upper side
means the node embedding
and these node embeddings are pulled to
generate the embedding of the graph
and we want the the quality of the node
and betty
and graph embedding to be both high
quality capture the semantics
and uh and uh this is a different from
the main
pre-training strategy where for example
if we
do not level per training we capture the
semantic at the level of nodes
but if those node embeddings are
globally aggregated we may not be able
to
obtain nice graphene embedding
or if we're only pre-training our gns at
the level of graph
we can obtain nice graphene bedding but
there's no guarantee that the before
aggregation
those node embeddings are of high
quality and this may
leads to a negative transfer because the
node embeddings are kind of not robust
so so in order to realize this
strategy to purchase units at the level
of both nodes and graphs
we we designed three concrete methods
um two self-supervised method
meaning there is no need for external
labels for another level per training
and one graph level of prediction of
pre-training strategy efficiency method
um that's uh that's supervised
so let me go through these three
concrete methods
okay so the first method is attribute
masking it's a low level pre-training
method
um the i algorithm is quite simple
so given that input graph we first mask
randomly mask node attributes so let's
say we mask these two node attributes in
the molecular graphs
please know that we are basically
masking the identity of the atom
and then we can use gns to generate a
node embeddings of these two
masked nodes and we use this node
embeddings to predict
the identity of the mask attributes so
here we want to use the node embedding
to predict that this x is a
is oxygen and this x is a carbon
and the intuition behind this is that
through solving the mass attribute
prediction test
our gnn is forced to learn the domain
knowledge
because it kind of needs to solve this
quiz
and uh and uh and and through this
solving this kind of quiz gnn
i can learn the the parameter of the gnn
can
capture the the chemistry domain
the next self-supervised task that we
propose is called
context prediction and and here
the idea the algorithm is as follows so
for each graph
we sample one center node let's say this
is a
red nose and we for this uh center node
we extract neighborhood and context
graph
so neighborhood graph is just the k-hop
neighborhood graph
in this case two hub neighbor graph like
this and then the context graph is a is
a surrounding graph
that's directly attached to this akihob
neighborhood graph
once we do extract this graph we can use
two separate gns to encode
this neighborhood graph into you know
one use one gns instant called this
neighbor could grab into a
vector another gene instead encode this
context graph
into a vector and our objective is to
maximize
or maximize the inner product between
the true
neighborhood context pair while
minimizing the inner product between
the false uh negative uh
uh force um neighborhood context pair
and these four pairs can be obtained by
randomly sample context graph from other
neighborhoods
and here the intuition is that we're
using we're assuming that sub graphs
that are surrounded by similar contexts
have
are semantically similar so we are
basically pushing
uh the embedding of the neighborhood
to be similar if they are have a similar
context graphs
and this is a kind of widely used uh
assumption in natural language
processing it's called distributional
hypothesis
so words that appear in the same similar
context have similar meaning
and it's exploited in the famous word to
deck model
um so
finally um i'm going to talk about this
uh
graph level pre-training task which is
essentially what i
introduced before also multi-task
supervised per training on many
relevant graphical labels and this is
really the direct approach
to inject domain knowledge into the
model
so to summarize the overall strategy we
perform
we first perform low level pre-training
to to obtain good note representation
we use that uh pre-chain parameter
to and then to to further perform
pre-training
uh at the level of graph using
supervised graph level pre-training
once once we've done uh this
both steps we fine-tune um
the parameters on the downstream tasks
that we care about
so this is the overall strategy and it
turns out that our strategy works out
pretty well as you can see this green
dots are our strategy
and our strategy first avoids the
negative transfer
in the sub two data sets and also
consistently
perform better than than this
orange naive strategy baseline across
the
data sets
and also um another interesting side
note is that
uh we fixed the pre-training strategy
and the pre-training different gns
models
use different genes model for
pre-training and what we found
out is that the most expressive gna
model
namely gene that we learned in the
lecture
benefits most from pre-training as you
can see here the gain
of non-pre-trained model versus
non-project model is the
is the largest um in terms of accuracy
and and the intuition here is that the
expressive
gna model can learn to capture more
domain knowledge than less expensive
model
especially learned from large amounts of
data
during pre-training
so to summarize of our gns
we've uh learned that the gns have
important application in scientific
domains like molecular
property prediction or um protein
function prediction
but those application domains present
the challenges of label scarcity
and out of distribution prediction and
we
argue that training is a promising
framework to tackle both of these
challenges
however we found that naive pre-training
strategy
of this simplifies graph level version
gives sub-optimal performance
and even leads to negative transfer and
our strategy is to
effective strategy is to pretend both
node and graph embeddings
and we found this strategy leads to a
significant performance gain
on diverse downstream tasks
yeah thank you for listening